mam et gus bonjour merci d'être en
direct sur rt france alors malgré l'aveu
de ses deux ex-soldats la maison blanche
ni toujours l'implication des etats-unis
peut-on ici parler de coup d'état selon
vous bonjour alors écoutez dix mois au
moins rafraîchi la mémoire
téléspectateurs qui nous regardent donc
le 3 mai dernier effectivement comme
vous l'avez souligné dans le petit
reportage juste avant il y a eu un
débarquement de plusieurs terroriste
vénézuélien est donc aussi des
mercenaires nord américain cette
opération avait été planifiée notamment
par juan garrido et ses partisans ses
acolytes
un contrat avait été signé avec une
entreprise de mercenaires étasunienne
monsieur jordan goudreau donc un ancien
béret vert des états unis avait
d'ailleurs souligné qu'il avait
effectivement signé un contrat avec
monsieur juan why do les assaillants
avaient d'ailleurs bénéficié en colombie
deux camps d'entraînement et notamment
des camps d'entraînement faisant partie
d'un territoire d'un arc aux trafiquants
notoires
elkin lopez donc c'est au jugement de
cette escapade meurtrière que nous
faisons face aujourd'hui avec la
condamnation en prend dans un premier
temps des mercenaires donc
nord-américain à 20 ans et neuf mois de
prison dont coup d'état non puisque il a
été déjoué par le peuple vénézuélien et
l'appui des forces armées nord a mis des
forces armées vénézuéliennes excusez moi
voilà nous assistons là aux séquelles de
cette aventure mercenaires qui
impliquait aussi dans le contrat
l'occupation du territoire c'est à dire
que le contrat signé dans l'uruguay
d'eau et l'entreprise de mercenaires
silver corp visait à éliminer messieurs
nicolás maduro le prix
nicolás maduro et de hauts dirigeants de
l'état vénézuélien est ensuite d'occuper
le territoire
c'était de mettre le pays à feu et à
sang dont c'est à ça que se sont
affrontés les les mercenaires américains
qui ont été capturés il y a quelques
mois
crispé les relations entre washington et
caracas avec ce jugement on peut
s'attendre à une poussée de tension en
tout cas entre les deux pays mais on
sait que cette affaire a été plusieurs
fois comparée à celle de la baie des
cochons en 1961 par caracas justement
est ce un parallèle justifié selon vous
écouter oui dans le dans le segment vous
prouve en tout cas des éléments de six
études c'est à dire une partie des xie
ou d'autres poésie gay vénézuélien comme
c'est aussi le cas dans le la lors de la
baie des cochons
en revanche la hausse et c'est l'aimant
pas dire au nouveau l'implication vu des
cartels de la drogue colombiens et
l'implication directe d'une personne qui
est reconnue ont produit mais je paie
par plusieurs pays occidentaux comme le
président par intérim autoproclamé du
tennis mais là donc là on voit bien
qu'ils payent à part des similitudes
l'intensité évidemment dit pas je
rappelle quand même que la baie des
cochons compter avec 1500 terroriste 1 à
l'époque
dans le cas du venezuela il y avait
croise élu le 25 militaires et
personnels alors dernière question c'est
que mike pompéo a réagi secrétaire
d'état américain a affirmé qu'il ferait
tout son possible pour libérer ces deux
anciens soldats quelles sont ses marges
de manoeuvre selon vous écouter
déjà la justice vénézuélienne et
indépendante n'est pas aux ordres des
états unis sache il a quand même d'un
crime très grave que je rappelle les
deux mercenaires sont accusés de
terrorisme et de de conspiration le but
de leur action était de mettre le pays à
feu et à sang déclencher une guerre
civile
donc effectivement comme c'est le cas
d'ailleurs dans n'importe quel autre
situation
le pays d'où sont issus les
ressortissants essaieront de négocier
une sortie de prison les marges de
manoeuvre sont évidemment assez réduite
puisque comme je voulais dit la justice
vénézuélienne est complètement
indépendante n'est pas une justice aux
ordres de washington
toutefois il n'est pas à exclure des
processus de négociation entre caracas
et les états unis ont pas sur le moyen
long terme pour aix expatriés les deux
les deux personnes mises en cause merci
beaucoup
romain miguet d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
journaliste et fondateur du site les
deux rives point info